لكن تلتفت طهران على العقوبات الغربيه
وتحاول ايجاد البديل دوما في القطاع
المالي او النفطي وغيرهما البحث عن بديل
لنظام سويفت المالي العالمي بعد فصل ايران
عن شبكه سويفت وهو ما واجهت روسيا ايضا
بات هذا الامر نقطه التقاء مشتركه بين
البلدين ماليا ومصرفيا ولدا على العقوبات
الغربيه ربطت موسكو وطيران انظمتها
المصرفيه سعيا منهما للالتفاء للالتفاف
على الرقابه
الامريكيه والافلات منها بالمبادلات
الماليه وحذف الدولار من التبادل التجاري
فيما بينهما ماذا يعني ذلك يعني ان
المصارف الايرانيه ستتمكن من التواصل
المباشر مع البنوك الروسيه والاتصال مع
اكثر من مئه مصرف اجنبي غير روسي في اربع
عشره دوله وفي سبتمبر الماضي توشينا العمل
ببطاقه مير المصرفيه الروسيه في ايران
كخطوه تمهيديه انذاك لدمج نظام الدفع
المصرفيين مير الروسيه واجتاب الايراني
هذا ماليا غير ان طيران لم تكتفي بذلك
فقطاع النفط الايراني له طرقه للوصول الى
الاسواق الكبرى وتحديدا الى الصين اكبر
مستهلك للطاقه ثمه زياده ملحوظه في صادرات
النفط الايرانيه والحديث هنا عن ارتفاع
خلال اشهر بمتوسط حوالي مليون برميل النفط
يوميا كيف
رحلته شحنات النفط الايرانيات تصل الى
الصين عبر حلقات وصل وهي عده دول ومن
بينها ماليزيا قبل ان تستقر في الصين تشير
بيانات اداره معلومات الطاقه الامريكيه
وشركه كابلر عام 2021 الى ان حجم صادرات
ايران النطيه الى ماليزيا مثلا بلغت سته
واربعين في المئه وثمانيه وعشرين في المئه
للصين والسبعه في المئه لدول اخرى